[Musique]
mon invité est devenu verte sans être
écolo à ses débuts elle se définit à la
fois comme utopiste et réaliste ce qui
est plutôt rare dans notre paysage
politique
[Musique]
bonjour evaas bonjour alors après le bac
vous avez fait une licence de philo mais
aussi les secs une des grandes écoles de
commerce française sauf que c'était pas
du tout pour devenir une femme
d'affaires que vous avez fait cette
école vous l'avez fait je cite dans une
perspective subversive un peu par
antrisme ça veut dire quoi c'est-à-dire
j'ai constaté moi mon père est d'une
famille ouvrière polonaise des Ardennes
et j'ai constaté que les ouvriers
étaient quand même soumis et qu'il
fallait leur donner les clés en fait
pour pouvoir gagner leur autonomie se
défendre et c'est dans ce sens là aussi
que moi j'ai voulu connaître le monde de
l'entreprise connaître les clés les
réflexions des actionnaires de façon à
pouvoir les donner finalement à ceux qui
en ont le plus besoin les salariés ceux
qui dans le rapport de force en fait
sont la partie faible donc vous étiez
dans une perspective politique sauf que
vous vouliez changer le système en
quelque sorte sauf que ça passait pas
par l'engagement politique moi j'étais
comme beaucoup de gens de cette
génération et peut-être encore les
jeunes aujourd'hui d'ailleurs très
méfiante des partis politiques j'avais
l'impression que c'était pas comme ça
qu'on pouvait changer le monde et que il
fallait être dans l'action au plus près
du monde de travail des salariés pour
rééquilibrer les rapports de force vous
avez un côté très méthodique un peu
rigoureux assez rigoureux même vous êtes
venus avec votre petit cahier
aujourd'hui par exemple vous avez cette
méthode cette rigueur ça vous a valu
d'être trésorière de votre propre parti
pendant longtemps d'être Vice-Présidente
de la commission des finances à
l'Assemblée aussi et ça vous empêche pas
de vous revendiquer de ce que vous
appelez l'utopie concrète ou encore la
radicalité réaliste on peut faire
cohabiter ces notions là sans les
dénaturer oui moi je pense que la
radicalité le réalisme pour être
vraiment radical il faut être réaliste
il faut savoir comment on va changer les
choses il s'agit pas de faire des
grandes déclarations mais d'être
justement dans le concret de détailler
les choses de maîtriser les outils et
c'est ce que j'essaye de faire
effectivement je vais plutôt un modèle
de cerveau en quelque sorte j'aime
décortiquer vraiment les sujets au plus
profond pour maîtriser les outils
échanger réellement les choses pas être
dans la déclamation c'est pour ça que
pour moi ça s'oppose pas du tout bien au
contraire pour être radical il faut être
réaliste alors ce côté un peu utopique
on le retrouve dans votre premier
engagement vous avez évoqué là d'un mot
votre première engagement politique
parce que vous êtes présenté au
législatives en 1997 pas sur l'écologie
c'était pour défendre la semaine de
quatre jours aux côtés de Pierre
laroutureoux votre rêve c'était en fait
de travailler moins en quelque sorte
c'est un peu le chômage qui a déclenché
votre engagement c'est ça l'idée c'est
exactement ça oui moi je sors de mes
études en 1993 c'est un pic dans le
chômage des jeunes je me rends compte
que toute une génération est un peu
laissée de côté je cherche vraiment des
solutions au chômage et je tombe sur
cette tribune dans Le Monde je crois qui
défend la semaine de quatre jours et le
partage du temps de travail je me dis ça
c'est la solution ça c'est à la fois
pragmatique ça change vraiment les
choses et je m'engage dans un mouvement
qui est associatif en fait à la base qui
s'appelait un nouvel équilibre ou la
semaine de quatre jours et on se
présente aux élections en l'occurrence
au législatives aux européennes mais
c'est pour défendre nos idées c'est des
candidatures de témoignages en quelque
sorte de 0,8 oui c'est ça je crois 0,86
c'est vraiment une candidature des
témoignages mais on se servait de cette
tribune que sont les législatives pour
défendre le partage du temps de travail
c'était d'ailleurs dans l'air du temps
puisque peu de temps après son passé les
35 heures alors c'est de fil en aiguille
à travers ce premier engagement que vous
avez fini par découvrir et rejoindre les
vers c'était en l'an 2000 mais à
l'époque ce qui a déclenché votre
engagement au sein des vers c'est pas
forcément la dimension écologique de
leur programme alors vous dites
écologique c'est pas forcément la
dimension environnementale et moi
effectivement les verres organisent à ce
moment-là les états généraux de
l'écologie politique et je rejoins ces
états généraux et je découvre le
programme et je le dis souvent j'étais
écolo sans le savoir parce que je
croyais naïvement et je pense qu'il y a
encore beaucoup de gens qui le croient
encore aujourd'hui que les Verts c'était
uniquement l'environnement et donc moi
j'avais donné priorité à l'époque plutôt
aux questions sociales et je découvre
dans ces états généraux que le programme
des vers c'est bien notre chose que ça
c'est évidemment le partage du temps de
travail la société du temps libérée
c'est autonomie responsabilité
solidarité les valeurs des Verts c'est
un projet de société globale qui donne
d'ailleurs cette autonomie à l'individu
qui fait en sorte que chacun soit maître
de son destin donc je me retrouve
complètement en fait dans ces dans ces
valeurs et je découvre que le programme
social et le programme démocratique des
Verts est très étoffé que c'est un
projet de société globale et je m'engage
pleinement jusqu'à aujourd'hui alors par
la suite vous avez occupé des fonctions
importantes chez les Verts vous avez
aussi été élu municipal député à deux
reprises mais pendant longtemps vous
avez refusé de vous consacrer
entièrement à la politique pour vous il
était important de garder un métier un
vrai métier pourquoi
je suis fier de l'être de l'avoir c'est
je suis expert auprès des représentants
du personnel expert auprès desse et pour
moi c'était d'abord et avant tout le
gage de l'indépendance en politique ne
pas dépendre de la politique pour gagner
sa vie ça nous donne une liberté très
importante j'avais constaté dans mes
premiers engagements que certains élus
changés de partie pour garder leur
mandat j'avais trouvé ça très triste et
je voulais jamais me retrouver dans
cette situation sur ces sur les idées
pour pouvoir garder son son gain de
pince absolument et puis vous savez
quand on s'engage chez les Verts c'est
pas pour faire carrière en politique
c'est très aléatoire je les écologistes
donc mieux vaut avoir un métier c'est un
métier passion en plus un métier que
j'aime énormément auquel je reviendrai
si c'est nécessaire et ce qui
m'intéresse c'est que donc vous l'avez
dit vous étiez dans un cabinet
d'expertise qui accompagne les syndicats
il s'appelle ce café
et c'est le slogan de ce cabinet qui a
attiré un peu votre regard réconcilier
l'économique et le social quand j'ai vu
ça en fait je me suis dit mais c'est en
fait c'est un programme politique ce
slogan c'est vrai mais là vous avez fait
de la politique à travers votre métier
absolument oui c'est un métier qui en
tout cas engagé qui vise à donner
justement à la partie faible au salarié
au représentant du personnel les outils
pour se défendre non pas à les défendre
à leur place et c'est ça que j'ai trouvé
bien aussi dans ce métier mais à leur
donner toutes les clés pour qu'ils
puissent se défendre et être à armes
égal avec la le même niveau
d'information que les représentants des
actionnaires les patrons il y a un fil
rouge aussi dans votre engagement
politique c'est votre combat pour les
droits des femmes en 2013 durant votre
premier mandat vous êtes tombé enceinte
et là vous avez pris conscience que la
situation des femmes députés n'étaient
pas tout à fait normal on va réécouter
votre prise de parole à ce moment là
il est temps que nos institutions
évoluent pour prendre en compte la
féminisation progressive de nos
assemblées actuellement comme vous le
savez rien n'est prévu en cas de congé
maternité d'une élue et je vous demande
un peu plus une annéeement peut-être ce
soir monsieur le rapporteur et chers
collègues d'envoyer tout
particulièrement un message aux femmes
pour leur dire qu'elles ont toutes leurs
places dans la vie politique et dans
cette assemblée alors pour bien
comprendre votre prise de parole de
l'époque il faut savoir qu'une femme
députée qui est enceinte peut partir en
congé maternité sauf qu'en fait elle
sera pas remplacée absolument donc ça
veut dire laisser si on siège vide c'est
une responsabilité une culpabilité j'ai
envie de dire pour la femme qui a encore
jamais maternité parce que elle a
l'impression de ne pas remplir son
mandat moi ce que je proposais c'est que
elle puisse être remplacée par son
suppléant sa suppléante et afin de de
concilier finalement ce qui est le
quotidien Le normal d'une vie de femme
et puis ce mandat qu'on veut remplir
pleinement sauf que ça pas été possible
en fait vous avez pas été possible
d'abord la Constitution a été écrite par
des hommes et pour des hommes donc le
cas n'est même pas envisagé en fait pour
changer ça il faudrait réviser la
Constitution ça paraît étonnant mais
article de la Constitution effectivement
qui prévoit les cas où on peut être
remplacé par son suppléance ils sont
extrêmement rares et le congé maternité
n'en fait pas partie c'est un combat
qu'on nous devons encore mener je pense
que nous y arriverons parce qu'à
l'époque nous étions peu nombreuses à
être enceinte dans l'hémicycle
aujourd'hui je constate qu'il y en a
beaucoup plus grâce à la féminisation le
rajeunissement aussi de l'hémicycle donc
c'est devant nous mais je pense qu'il
faudrait quand même accélérer parce que
cette intervention ma fille a 9 ans donc
elle t'a dit à 9 ans et on a vu
récemment plusieurs cas de femmes
députés enceintes certaines avec des
autres responsabilités comme Aurore
berger présidente du groupe Renaissance
donc de la de la majorité présidentielle
et les choses ont toujours pas changé
c'est vrai que c'est un peu triste de
voir le temps qu'on met pour des choses
aussi évidentes
beaucoup d'autres parlements et au
Parlement européen c'est tout à fait
possible et prévu donc je trouve qu'on
est en retard et qu'il faut
effectivement avancer un peu plus vite
sur ce sujet pour revenir sur le débat
que vous avez déclenché à l'époque ça
fait ça a suscité pas mal de réactions
peu de femmes politiques vous ont
soutenu il y en a même qui ont eu des
réactions plutôt hostiles comme Michel
laliomari on va voir ce qu'elle a dit à
l'époque pendant qu'on y est pourquoi
pas remplacer un homme qui se casse la
jambe d'abord il y a un vrai sujet les
longues maladies ne sont pas non plus
ça vous a étonné ce genre de réaction
venant de la part de femmes politiques
non ça m'a pas complètement étonné parce
que j'ai observé que le féminisme n'est
pas partagé par toutes les femmes et en
particulier il faut le dire et les moins
présent chez les femmes de droite et qui
a une façon parfois chez certaines
femmes de vouloir cacher l'aspect
féminin en l'occurrence le fait d'être
enceinte dans leur action politique les
femmes qui veulent revenir tout de suite
dans l'hémicycle qui veulent
ils ne veulent pas parler de leur
maternité je trouve ça dommage il faut
assumer entièrement il n'y a pas avoir
honte il n'y a pas à se sentir coupable
de vivre sa vie de femme en même temps
que nous nous exercons notre monde à ce
on me voit là en train de prendre la
parole enceinte dans l'hémicycle mais
vous-même vous êtes allé assez loin si
on peut dire dans votre grossesse en
restant présente à l'assemblée c'est
vous étiez tiraillé dans ce cette forme
de conflit de loyauté on va dire entre
vos électeurs d'un côté et votre futur
bébé votre famille de l'autre mais c'est
exactement ça on nous a confié un mandat
donc s'absenter longuement c'est
évidemment une culpabilité pour pour les
élus que nous sommes et je ne souhaite
pas que ça perdure parce que nous
n'avons pas à subir cela alors on va
passer à notre quiz à présent je vous
explique le principe je vais commencer
une phrase et ça va être à vous de la
compléter on y va oui alors le plus dur
quand on est une femme députée justement
c'est
le regard des hommes le regard des
hommes parce que il y a encore
énormément du regard sur quoi sur votre
façon de faire de la politique il y a
toujours une forme de mépris et de
condescendance et on l'observe encore
aujourd'hui dans les dans l'hémicycle
peut-être encore plus quand on est une
femme écologiste il y a cette a priori
qu'on va être moins compétentes que on
va être plus hystérique comme disait les
hommes et que il faut toujours démontrer
alors que chez les hommes c'est
finalement un acquis on ne demande pas
la même preuve de compétence aux hommes
et c'est encore le cas aujourd'hui
malheureusement pour un député la
semaine de quatre jours c'est
inexistant trop totalement utopiste pas
du tout réaliste non mais je pense qu'il
y a une réflexion à avoir effectivement
sur la charge de travail d'ailleurs
qu'on a en tant que député je pense que
c'est relativement inaudible comme débat
aujourd'hui et nous remplissons notre
tâche entièrement mais je le partage du
temps de travail il vaut pour tout le
monde et que le temps libéré et la
société du temps libéré à laquelle nous
inspirons tous ils doivent alors aussi
pour les élus c'est une aspiration de
tout un chacun elle vaut aussi pour nous
enfin être subversif à l'Assemblée c'est
là aussi peut-être être à la commission
des finances et porter des sujets
radicaux j'ai choisi la commission des
finances aussi pour ça parce que je ne
pense que ça ne dit pas ça ne doit pas
être un débat entre experts le
changement de société qu'on nous
souhaitons voir advenir il passe aussi
par les débats de finances publiques
donc une fois de plus maîtriser les
outils les maîtriser bien pour les
renverser et pour vraiment avoir une
société plus juste plus écologique plus
environnementale et plus solidaire merci
beaucoup merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation merci
[Musique]